welcome to this video playing [ __ ] car
off check her off I am so named here
nope what about the Sicilian just
something else everybody plays this now
yeah I always most anticipated to move
yeah the open Sicilian seems to be a
species in decline let's say it doesn't
doesn't happen that often anymore
against this okay I know I know it's
crude but Jack it's not a bad line and
they don't take one c4 I think they
reroute reroute it to deform yeah flex
setup is not is interesting and
ambitious and everything but it is also
very slow
well where's to come for the pony
something with a five but I can take
that right I can take that form so i
don't quite don't quite see it might be
for Queen takes d5 yeah so just here he
will take on a form maybe not checking
him yeah chats not bad and now i can
take c4 maybe as 94 it's not possible
i'm taking on g7 is risky probably so
let's take it taking on g7 i go rook
evade and then Bishop e7 castles long
wow I think that open G file could be
tricky for white skin with the bishop on
b7 lon Castle Rock g8 how does he
prevent that I'd be very interested in
learning how he does that okay does this
move okay so age 6 I guess
it's difficult to cover g8 n to the
diagonal here to prevent my canceling
and group G hate coming that's it for
the Queen white resides Joe very weird
that Bishop a phone with him every
Bishop f4 is ok but just a fourth
strange why I mean Knight takes e4 is a
very obvious idea and he didn't didn't
do anything against it huh so
interestingly enough the engine is
giving equal with rookie d1 interesting
yeah I have no development here in the
dark squares are somewhat weak so this
is what the engine wants to do something
like that that is maybe compensation I
rook to d6 that could be equal no very
difficult for black to get anything
going yeah that's it that's okay in fact
but yeah I'm having my doubts yah him
now black has a clear advantage check ok
that's funny the engine gives Queen g2
with a good position for wide because it
gets a 94 and wow so I oh I made a
mistake then I was really secure that's
not working at all I mean like know
wherever but probably not this is me I
have to play a different monster now
Queen f5 is better ok hmm it's quite
amazing I was thinking I'm completely
winning at this position but he has that
form 94
it's funny funny line check check check
and black has some compensation for the
exchange maybe it's even enough but ok
not what I thought I have yeah here just
lost them yeah that's just lost and I'm
getting the g file mmm bit of a bit of a
weird game ok well thanks for watching